You now know the basics of finding,
installing and enabling a plugin.
I've provided you a link in the notes,
but the search for
autoprefixer plus gulp on Google would
have reveled the MPM plugin right away,
and installation process is the same.
MPM installer gulp-autoprefixer
in the terminal.
And in a requirement of the gulp file.
Here's the key part.
The autoprefixer object is just
another receiver of a pipe dream.
Pipe stream.
I was just testing if
you're listening closely.
And since we already have
a pipe coming from Sass,
we simply add a new line right before
it arrives at its destination.
Like so.
Almost there.
We finally insert a configuration object
to specify the browser's option of
autoprefixer, which tells autoprefixer
for which browser versions to prefix.
In this case,
we'll just instruct it to use the last
two versions of every popular browser.
And as step two of three, see the filter
property used on the image in main.scss?
Remove the prefix,
then rerun gulp styles in the terminal.
And here's the generated CSS file
with all the right prefixes.
Excellent.